[Musique]
chasselay c'est la vie il est pour nous
un travail ou bab l'aimé ou amour est un
pur fait marrer
[Musique]
marc gental
au niveau du lit et ouais même un petit
carré semble à transporter aubagne est
un sport
[Musique]
m
mais messieurs
continuer j'ai besoin de ta passion et
je trouve ça fabuleux
je suis pas branché sentiment je suis
plutôt super à voir aujourd'hui tu pas
oublié
tous les tocards qui n'ont pas assuré y
a pas que la presse dans la
il ya le sexe
c'est sympa
et encore
[Musique]
on parle et c'est elle qui sait
pas besoin de me faire un dessin
après 91 ans et tu sais de faire la
planche tiens voilà ton étalons qui
enlève son pantalon
il cède à 20khz émotions
que je dois aux fruits de la passion
[Musique]
de la bascule
qui de la passion
et de la passion
[Musique]
de la patience
et de la passion
au tir et de la passion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dernier
par
ailleurs
on va chanter la manif
[Musique]
antic
la passion
de la passion
[Musique]